[Music]
on this sunday night state of emergency
ottawa's flipper helped to deal with the
ongoing protest this is a siege and what
u.s support the canadian truckers are
heroes could mean for the demonstration
rolling back restrictions the prairie
provinces promising to lift pandemic
measures return to sender we're really
concerned and disappointed the radical
changes that could be coming to canada
post and losing sleep the growing
reliance on melatonin most people use it
incorrectly and why it's not the natural
fix many think it is
global national reporting tonight
colleen christie
good evening thanks for joining us our
nation's capital is under a state of
emergency tonight late today ottawa's
mayor made the decision saying the
ongoing protest poses a serious danger
and threat to the safety and security of
residents the declaration will give the
city new powers around the procurement
and delivery of essential services but
as mike trolley explains in our top
story tonight ottawa is still calling on
the federal and provincial governments
for help
the day started out peaceful in the
nation's capital promises had been made
by organizers out of respect for
religious services truckers would lay
off their horns until 1 pm
they didn't make it to 10.
10 days into the occupation of ottawa
it's evolving into a carnival or party
atmosphere for the protesters for local
residents and businesses it's anything
but
city officials are at a loss with what
to do this is a siege it is something
that is different in our democracy than
i've ever experienced you're not going
to arrest your way out of this problem
i think chief slowly has made that very
clear this is a political protest there
is no law enforcement solution to a
political protest
the police may not be arresting
protesters on mass but they're no longer
allowing them the freedom they
previously enjoyed announcing anyone
transporting fuel to the protesters
could be arrested an encampment a block
south of parliament in confederation
park was deemed unsafe and while protest
leaders in branded freedom convoy
jackets cooperated they said their
demands remain unchanged we just request
that the prime minister comes out and
talk to us you just want to sit down you
want him to want to talk
and they're willing to wait as long as
it takes to get what they want they
certainly don't have to worry about
money anymore having raised two and a
half million dollars in the last day
alone that amount of money gives them
the freedom to wait
it also buys them notoriety canadian
truckers are heroes and the attention of
a growing number of right-wing
politicians in the us
lessons from the past suggests
it's best not to engage with the
americans or tell them
how to engage
how to do their business when it comes
to canada because that risks
galvanizing significant political and
financial forces in the united states
the voices are certainly getting louder
here in canada for some form of federal
intervention there's no way prime
minister justin trudeau will be able to
ignore them if he goes to his office
they're barbecuing right outside
microlite global news ottawa
the federal government is closely
watching what's happening in ottawa
speaking on the west block today public
safety minister marco mendicino said
calling in the military is a last resort
instead the federal government will rely
on police to end the demonstration
we want to rely on the law enforcement
to deal with a public uh order event uh
this is not a military
operation the military and its purpose
are not designed to keep the peace uh
locally in our communities uh so it's
obviously a
last resort in the meantime it's
important that auto police do their jobs
on the ground
and you can watch the full interview
with public safety minister marco
mendicino coming up on the west block
right here on global
in southern alberta protesters continue
to slow traffic heading towards the busy
coots border crossing demonstrators are
in it for the long haul saying they
won't leave until vaccine mandates and
covid19 restrictions are removed the
premiers of alberta and saskatchewan say
their governments will start rolling
back public health measures this week
but as heather urex west explains
medical experts say that could be a
mistake
the road to alberta's busiest border
crossing remains open but the protesters
have not gone away
for several days rcmp have remained at
the site of two illegal protests traffic
is getting through but the crowd
continues to cause significant delays
protesters vowing to stay put until not
just the federal vaccine mandate for
cross-supporter truckers is lifted but
until every last coven 19 restriction
goes away no responsible government
makes policy by negotiating with people
engaged in such unlawful conduct period
full stop
still the premiers of both alberta and
saskatchewan have promised that
provincial restrictions including proof
of vaccine programs will not be in place
much longer covett is not ending but
government restrictions on your rights
and freedoms those will be ending and
ending very soon
both provinces plan to roll out details
early this week but with health care
systems still under pressure medical
experts have concerns from a medical and
from a public health perspective this is
not optimal by any means alberta and
saskatchewan have been down this road
before
after lifting all restrictions last
summer both provinces experienced a
delta-fueled fourth wave that
overwhelmed hospital icus many people
lost their lives irretrievably i mean a
lot you know people families you know
lost their
their loved ones and hospitalization
numbers are even higher now doctors
aren't alone in these fears the way
the government opened it up for stampede
last year really actually kind of pissed
me off because it was like hey there's
no covid we're fine hey party do
whatever you want so let's open up
responsibly
and because i don't want to be shut down
again there may be a divide on how to
proceed but after two long years
everyone is so tired of kovit 19.
heather eurex west global news calgary
the race to replace aaron o'toole is
already underway conservative mp pierre
poliev has launched a bid to be the next
leader of the federal conservatives he
made the announcement in a video posted
on social media but he doesn't mention
the party by name instead he says he's
running for prime minister
trudeau thinks he's your boss
he's got it backwards
you are the boss
that's why i'm running for prime
minister to put you back in charge of
your life
together
we will make canadians the freest people
on earth
the video and polyes emphasis on freedom
in a country that is already one of the
freest in the world is drawing
comparisons to tactics used by former
u.s president donald trump west block
host mercedes stephenson asked former
conservative cabinet minister john baird
if he thinks poliev will use american
style politics during his leadership
campaign
donald trump when he ran didn't talk
about the republican party he talked
about himself is pierre polyam going to
do this creating a cult of personality
because he's not talking about the
conservative party you're running for
that he's talking about pierre pauliov
and running to be prime minister as if
the leadership race is over yeah i i
reject the comparisons wholeheartedly
he's not uh he's not that type of
politician he's demonstrably more
thoughtful demonstrably more experienced
i think what you're going to see is a
pierre present himself as a as an
incredibly popular leader of the
conservative party and then present
himself as a viable candidate to be
prime minister poliev is the first
person to throw a hat into the ring to
replace o'toole who was forced out last
week
ukraine remains on high alert tonight as
more russian troops lined the border u.s
government officials say russia has
assembled 70 percent of the forces
needed to launch a full-scale invasion
of ukraine more american troops are now
on the ground in poland and germany to
bolster nato's eastern flank jennifer
johnson has the latest on the spiraling
tensions
russian ground attack aircraft arrived
in belarus for joint military exercises
part of a significant military buildup
along the border with ukraine
ukraine's allies are building their
support too the u.s has brought in more
soldiers and military supplies to poland
part of a 3 000 troop deployment to
eastern europe during this period of
uncertainty
we know that
we are stronger together american
soldiers are training ukrainian fighters
as they prepare to possibly fight the
over 110 000 russian soldiers marshaling
on the border i think we need to
say them welcome to the hell
while russian president vladimir putin
denies it's planning to attack the
former soviet republic the biden
administration isn't buying it we
believe that there is a very distinct
possibility that vladimir putin will
order an attack on ukraine it could
happen as soon as tomorrow or it could
take some weeks yet
ukraine's government insists resolving
tensions with russia through diplomacy
are greater than the threat of an attack
they believe russia is sending a message
to stop ukraine from joining nato
protesters and a majority of the
population want ukraine to join nato
which would significantly bolster its
international military backing
putin is in china gaining support from
president xi jinping who issued
statements opposing nato's expansion and
blaming the u.s for the rising tensions
the u.s is ready to slap severe economic
sanctions against russia should it
invade to try and crush putin and the
billionaires who back him on a daily
basis russian financial institutions do
about 46 billion dollars worth of
financial transactions
around the world
eighty percent of those transactions are
in dollars the u.s has support from its
allies including canada to pressure
putin and his wealthy backers now it's
up to putin whether he wants to take the
path of diplomacy or war
jennifer johnson global news washington
meanwhile team canada's snowboarders are
riding high for gold with three heading
to the men's slope style finals mark
mcmorris max perrault and sebastian
tutton all made the top 12 at the end of
sunday's qualifiers mcmorris who
finished second is a two times bronze
medalist perrault won silver in 2018
where touton won gold in big air
snowboarding
coming up how canadians responded when
asked should canada post service be
reduced
changes could be coming to canada post
global news has learned the federal
government has been exploring the idea
of making some radical adjustments to
mail delivery in this country
internal government polling commissioned
by the minister in charge of canada post
asked canadians several questions
including if they supported cutting mail
service and replacing workers with
machines our chief political
correspondent david aiken has the
details on the polling and the reaction
david
weeks into her new job as minister in
charge of the post office philomena
tassie had her aides put a poll in the
field asking canadians how they felt
about some potentially significant
changes to canada post for example the
poll asked about closing rural post
offices seventy percent said no don't do
that
how about replacing postal workers with
machines that wasn't such a hot idea
forty five percent opposed but what
about ending all home delivery and
moving all of that to community
mailboxes 48
like that idea and cutting mail delivery
to three times a week 52 percent were on
board
those numbers are all from internal
government polling obtained by global
news through an access to information
request canada post itself did not ask
for the poll and didn't even know about
it the questions all came from the
trudeau government the fact that the
government's even exploring cutting
services instead of supporting canada
post and looking at ways of innovation
and investments to expand services to
canadians like postal banking things
that we've been calling for
it's just unbelievable the union
representing canada post 61 000 workers
says it found some of the questions in
the poll from tassie's office offensive
you know for us we're really concerned
and disappointed the government is
actually taking a poll right now but
reducing postal services when the public
is actually asking them to um you know
to have more services not less they want
us to expand services
and even though canada post no longer
receives direct taxpayer subsidies the
poll asked about that and found that
only 39 said the government should
continue to provide financial support to
cover canada post losses but 50 told the
minister's poll it was time to
restructure the crown corporation to
break even neither minister tassie nor
anyone else in the government would
agree to an interview but a spokesperson
did tell us that none of these poll
questions indicate any future direction
or policy instead
they were just there to help minister
tassie measure how canadians feel about
the post office and mail delivery david
aiken global news ottawa
melatonin misinformation ahead of
caution about the common sleep
supplement
you're watching global national
[Music]
one of india's most beloved singers
whose beautiful voice was the soundtrack
to hundreds of bollywood films has died
at the age of 92. thousands gathered to
pay respects at a state funeral today
prime minister narendra modi was there
and wrote on twitter the coming
generations will remember lada
mangeshkar as a stalwart of indian
culture whose melodious voice had an
unparalleled ability to mesmerize people
the pandemic is having a significant
impact on mental health some canadians
are reporting increased anxiety stress
and difficulty unplugging all of those
issues can make it hard to get a good
night's sleep and that's prompted some
people to turn to melatonin but as jamie
morocco reports researchers say it's not
without health risks
emergency room nurse jason powell knows
how easy it is for frontline staff to
miss out on sleep right now with the
amount of staff absences and the
concurrent pressures with patient
complexity sleep deprivation and just
being tired is just the norm especially
throughout this pandemic for shift
workers melatonin is a common and
seemingly simple solution a naturally
occurring hormone it regulates your
sleep wake cycles and it can be found in
pill form a new study out this week
reveals in the u.s use of the
over-the-counter supplement is
increasing but unlike prescription drugs
melatonin is considered a natural
product by both the us fda and health
canada and therefore not fully regulated
researchers have found the pills may not
contain the amount of melatonin
advertised on the label some of them
only had a quarter of what they said
they had and others had five times as
much and some of them also had other
contaminants in them so it's
unfortunately very difficult to get a
good reliable supply at this calgary
clinic experts have noticed an increase
in the amount of people struggling with
sleep jonathan cherry says more time
spent in front of a screen is likely to
blame
if you are
blasting your brain with light
such as blue light you will reduce the
secretion of melatonin but he says
supplementing melatonin is almost never
the answer most people use it
incorrectly
and then when it doesn't work you will
either increase the dose or you will
couple it with something else instead
experts suggest shutting off any screens
at least 30 minutes before heading to
bed and making sure your sleep space is
quiet and dark if that isn't working
it's time to consult a professional the
last thing that we want is our own sleep
deprivation and our own
lack of personal physical and mental
health to translate into an unsafe work
environment focusing on personal health
in order to care for others health jamie
morocco global news toronto
next the road to queen elizabeth's
unprecedented platinum jubilee
britain's longest reigning monarch has
the crown's future in mind she's
expressing support for prince charles's
wife camilla wishing her to become queen
consort once charles is king the
announcement comes as part of a
statement for the queen's platinum
jubilee it's been exactly 70 years since
elizabeth took the throne after her
father's death and as britain celebrates
the unprecedented milestone redmond
shannon looks at the long and bumpy road
leading up to it
you might say this is william roach
during queen elizabeth's 70th year on
the throne the world's longest reigning
monarch visited the world's longest
running soap opera the aptly named
coronation street one of tens of
thousands of engagements over her
remarkable reign seven decades that
began in east africa
it was on february 6 1952 that her
husband prince philip broke the news
during a visit to kenya her father king
george had died and she was now queen
it would be more than a year later
before the official coronation ceremony
when a struggling post-war britain was
transfixed by a young queen
a number of families went to
a neighbor's house the only neighbor in
the street who had a television
and we were all crammed into their
front room princess elizabeth was seen
symbolically to represent the
possibility of some public flowering of
a new elizabethan age royal commentator
richard fitzwilliams says the first
decades of her reign were relatively
smooth until the crisis of the 1990s you
had the so-called anas herbalists in
1992
that year saw the marriages of three of
her children fall apart under the public
gaze there was a major fire at windsor
castle and a tussle over whether the
royals should pay income tax
the absolute low point of her reign came
in 1997 when the british public angrily
demanded the queen return to london
after the death of princess diana
but from that moment on her popularity
rose and has stayed high since polls
suggest a strong support in britain for
the royal institution she exemplifies
duty and service to the country which is
why we in the army sort of love her so
much
through the highs of the royal weddings
of the 2010s to the recent lows of the
departure of prince harry from royal
duties as well as the ongoing
allegations of sexual assault against
her son prince andrew and of course the
death of her husband prince philip we've
seen the queen as an exemplar of what an
ideal monarch should be at the age of 95
and after a hospital stay last fall her
duties are being scaled back to match
her years but she is showing little
desire to retire from her life of duty
least of all during this record-breaking
jubilee year redmond shannon global news
london
and that is global national for this
sunday night i'm colleen christie
tonight your canada is calgary alberta
we love to see your corner of the
country so please keep sending your
photos to viewers at globalnational.com
thanks for watching donna friesen will
be back at the anchor desk tomorrow have
a great night
[Music]
you